by the way peter i was reading this and
i saw a bug um you your my your printing
here doesn't actually print the float
because you forgot the parameter so just
a heads up i was reading this earlier
like last week or something and i was
like huh that's funny unreliable guide
confirmed
it's going in your performance review
peter
this beautiful
open source piece of information that
you published
which no one asked you to do is missing
stuff so sorry
that reminds me um
of like those games you play where like
you can lose score
so it's kind of like you know what i
mean like imagine if in basketball
you're playing basketball and if you
like take the shot but you miss you like
lose two points
so it's like it's better not to take the
shot
than it is because you might lose score
that's what this reminds me of it's like
peter did some work peter did some nice
work on his own accord but unfortunately
he meant he messed it up so he was that
actually okay guys story time true story
i had this subject in university called
database programming and the person like
we had so many issues with the person
running that course but basically the
way that they marked
the the exam
is like
okay so 70 of the class failed
we're going to interrupt this for a
little story time right a little story
time break so uh database programming
the year
is 2016 i believe
was it
maybe it was 2014.
i don't know if it was 2014 or 2016.
but anyway it was one of those two years
definitely wasn't 2015 because that's
the year that i was interning at ea
yeah so basically database programming
and
um we had we had this like test we had
this like kind of exam it wasn't really
like an exam like an end of semester
exam but we were sitting in the lecture
theater and we were doing basically an
exam right and this was like a hurdle
exam which means that if you don't pass
it
like you can't pass the unit you can't
wait they called subjects units we can't
pass the unit without passing this
assignment basically which was like a
written paper
70 of the class
did not pass it
because the way that this person marked
this
and and by that extension 70 of
of the students failed the unit right
because the way that this person marked
it is a question you'd get an entire
page to answer a question this was
related to databases and stuff
um and like really really annoying
database stuff so like you know
transactions and like probably some java
libraries like there's one called like
so let's start with like the letter h or
i don't know it's weird um i remember
this stuff because it's useless but
basically entire page to answer the
question it's worth 10 marks yeah i
think it was probably hibernate yeah
something like that maybe
um but basically
entire question entire page to answer
the question it's worth 10 marks and
you you read your answer and you're like
how did i get zero marks for this 10
mark question
and the reason why
was because the way this person marked
is if you mention something that was not
correct
or
you mentioned something in your answer
that they deemed wasn't 100
relevant
to the question so you know how when
you're writing you know a one-page
answer you might
mention some stuff that you know that
might not be a hundred percent relevant
to the question but it also shows what
you know and also you do generally i'm
not saying you don't answer the question
at all you just go on a longer
explanation and you explain a few more
things
so anytime you do that or you get
something wrong minus five marks
so if you do too little little issues
too little issues in your one-page
response
that's zero
that's down from 10 marks to zero for
that question and there were maybe 12 of
those questions or so in the thing
so get this guys so the the kind of
person in charge of this course not the
subject but the course in the university
after hearing that 70 percent of the
students failed
this unit
right swooped in and said to the
lecturer to the person who was leading
or convening this unit of study
said to them
i'm sorry you can't fail 70 of the class
you just you can't fail 70 in the class
like if if 70 of your class is failing
then clearly you are doing something
wrong like that's impossible
and so what ended up happening was
we all got called in one by one
into this
person
into this person's
office
one by one
we sat down like it was funny it was
really funny right because they were
like what i don't know at least 50
people probably doing this subject
so there's a line of like 70 i guess a
50 however much that is
like 35 or whatever people
there's this line of like 30 something
people
on like the fourth floor of this
building all the way going to this
person's office who get called in one by
one sat down
and then the lecturer the person
chartered the unit explains to them
what they did wrong and how dare they
and then you say yes i'm sorry forgive
me
please i'm sorry i tried and then they
ask you the question you're like okay so
explain it and then you uh you kind of
explain it and then they're like okay
fine good enough past
so what's funny is guys
i'm a good student like
i don't need to
i don't know if i want to reveal the
university i went to
but
i will somewhat
i will somewhat censor this it's gonna
be hard to see this but look at this i
don't think i've ever shown anyone this
well on stream at least
i got this prize you know what prize
this is this is the prize for the
highest achieving graduate in this
entire course
now guys i don't know how i got this i'm
going to be completely honest with you
i do not think i don't know how this
happened
the class must have been really bad
because i did not even get close to like
a hundred percent and this is across the
whole course
right
i did not get a hundred percent i think
i got maybe an average of 90. i mean i
was a high distinction average student
but i think i got about 90. i don't know
how and so what happened was
like and i swear you know i'm not one of
those people who is actually like really
smart and is like being all like oh yeah
i guess i'm not that smart like i am
serious when i say i do not real i do
not deserve this at all like i'm not
saying that to be modest i'm saying that
because it's factual
but anyway
wait i want to see if i can do a little
let me see if i can do a little zoom in
oh no you know what no why am i doing
that i'll just do this hold on
all right there it is proof
proof i mean i may have just printed
this certificate myself but that'd be
pretty low wouldn't it so the reason why
i brought this up by the way not to brag
or anything
but oh and that's a whole story in and
of itself because i was like the
university gave me a check for a
thousand dollars for this prize and i
was also i was also taken to
lunch
with the people who established this
foundation
because they're i think they're like
their son died unfortunately from cancer
and they established a foundation like
in his name
and that's like that foundation is what
gave me like the thousand dollars and
this certificate and i'm sitting there
at lunch being like and they're probably
thinking they're talking to like the
next i don't know mark zuckerberg or
like someone who's actually smart and
i'm like
yes i i study i uh
i like exams um anyway i felt so i don't
know i just felt kind of bad being there
because i'm like why am i like i just
don't i just don't understand how it
happened but anyway the reason why i
brought this up guys is because
to prove the fact that i was a good
student in university i got a high
distinction average but you know what i
got for database programming for that
unit
i got a 50
i got a pass
yeah
i got a pass which is like
the i got a 50 50 out of 100. if you get
below a 50 you don't pass it unless you
get a conceded pass which i think goes
down to 45 but i got a 50.
and i i know it was 2014. you know you
know how i know it's 2014 because at the
end of 2014
i was uh getting i was like interviewing
to get an internship at ea and i
remember i remember that stupid database
programming you know i was worried that
because i had to give them my academic
record like to ea so they'd i guess
they'd look at it or whatever not that
they cared like honestly i don't think
they cared but it was just a formality
and i was i remember i was worried
because i'm like dude they're gonna see
that pass and they're gonna be like this
guy's a this guy's a loser like because
every other subject that that semester i
did three other subjects i got a high
distinction but for that one it was a
pass
and i was like dude they're gonna see
that and they're gonna be like sorry
cherno we can't hire you like who gets a
pass
in like this like that you you clearly
suck but um i don't think they cared and
i remember yeah i remember oh what a
thing to be worried about though the one
pass the 150 i got in uh in my in my
entire degree and still guys with that
50 i got this that's why i don't
understand it there must have been a bug
there must have been a bug in the
computer system for me to get this award
i actually don't know how i got it
again being fully serious
all right anyway mono
back to mono